[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Actions on Google let
you bring your services
to the Google Assistant.
Your integrations can
help you engage users
through Google Home today and in
the future through Pixel, Allo,
and many other experiences
where the Google Assistant will
be available.
To learn more about this
awesome new platform,
use the link in the
description below.
We're wrapping up our
annual global Playtime
series of events where we met
with app and game developers
from around the
world to discuss how
to build successful
businesses on Google Play,
share experiences, give
feedback, collaborate,
and get inspired.
Don't worry if you missed it.
You can now watch some of
the best Playtime sessions
on our Android Developers
YouTube channel.
Highlights include a great
session on sustainable growth
and how you can use
augmented reality
to create innovative, immersive
experiences for your users--
all linked below.
Firebase Crash Reporting
is now fully released
with many new features
and enhancements
to help you better
diagnose and respond
to crashes that affect the
users of your iOS and Android
mobile apps, including issue
resolution, improved reporting
latency, and email alerts.
For more info and screenshots,
check out the post.
One of the main
challenges in exploring
data being interpreted
by ML models
is that it often has hundreds
or even thousands of dimensions,
requiring special tools
to investigate the space.
To enable a more intuitive
exploration process,
we are open-sourcing
a web application
for interactive
visualization and analysis
of high dimensional data
called the Embedding Projector.
Check out the post for some
cool animations of it in action.
DeepMind has invested
considerable effort
toward building rich
simulated environments that
serve as laboratories
for AI research.
They just open-sourced
their flagship platform
DeepMind Lab, which is a fully
3D game-like platform tailored
for agent-based AI research.
For the paper and
the GitHub link,
click on through to
the post linked below.
Remember the "No-Nonsense
Guide to Native Ads"?
It contains guiding
design principles
that help you better implement
native ads, practical tips
and best practices and examples
for implementing native ads,
how to set up a proper A/B test
to begin testing native ads,
and more.
Oh, and now, it's available in
Spanish and Japanese as well.
To download your copy, click
on through to the post.
Did you know that 22% more
mobile shoppers visited
retailers via Google
in the January
after the holiday season
than in the October before?
For more fun facts
and optimization tips
for key traffic-driving
categories in January,
check out the post.
This week, we announced the beta
release of the new Google Cloud
Client Libraries for
four of our cloud
services-- BigQuery, Google
Cloud Datastore, Stackdriver
Logging, and Google
Cloud Storage.
These client libraries
are well-documented,
easy to access, and cover 7
server-side languages-- C#, Go,
Java, Node.js, PHP,
Python, and Ruby.
We also recently announced
the general availability
of Regional Managed
Instance Groups
in Google Compute Engine.
This release offers a
fully managed service
for creating highly
available applications.
Simply specify the region in
which to run your application,
and Compute Engine automatically
balances your machines
across independent
zones within the region.
For more information and
to get started today,
check out the post.
Don't forget to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[KEYBOARD CLICKS]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks for
watching this week's episode
of "The Developer Show."
To watch some of our past
episodes, click on them
right over there.